[ __ ] boom you back up on the LSD trip
over here question me yes oh my god I
love it I love it everything about this
I love everything about this I am so
happy right now
oh I've never oh did you party a little
too hard he my bro shrek is love and
shrek is life give me a smooch baby I am
just bystander no gun that is what I am
I promise who is that I'm Zulu I if
that's Miko
[Laughter]
[Music]
why oh how I wish you would let me just
slide my two old I whoa that gets a
little bit graphic their slender man oh
my god
this tiny box Jim too late urge peer
pressure coming I think I'm a sonic
screwdriver Bonnie are you okay Bonnie
are you all right wow this is slightly
disturbing
bonnie if you just fasten your seatbelt
for a few seconds we'll be on the ground
sure you did it I'm gonna murder you
Jesus
[Music]
oh this is good
I like the paddle kick technique that
you got going on here little bit down
okay I don't know I know right now
I'm not even actually oh god these hips
that is my face
[Laughter]
boy you're an [ __ ]
good no okay well that's it you know
what that's it literally all that time
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more of a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye